hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast detection and analysis of
circulating tumor cells challenges and
solutions I am Christina mahalik of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kaya gen whether your passion for
answers takes you to a laboratory bench
or a hospital bedside the pursuit often
begins with a blood or tissue sample the
deepest mysteries of disease and other
biological processes the answers you
seek are encoded in the building blocks
of life DNA get the work of learning
what these molecules can tell tell you
is quite a journey and we Akaya j'en
understand the challenges associated
with this quest our commitment is to
enable you to quickly and reliably reach
your goal of useful actionable insights
to this end kyochon offers you
innovative solutions that cover every
single step along this journey not just
technologies but bridges from samples to
insights tables to insights means kaijin
offers you the industry's most reliable
sample technologies because samples
matter to your success our top quality
assays and panels enable you to
accurately analyze and identify diseases
and genetic variations our
bioinformatics software and curated
knowledge bases transform your raw data
into relevant actionable findings and
our automation solutions provide you
seamless and cost-effective workflows
sample to insight the insights you gain
may lead to one small step or a giant
leap forward for science and health care
partnering with kyochon your work can
make a difference for more information
please visit kyochon comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
the webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can
additionally you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left corner this is an educational
webinar and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
for obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Siegfried couch director of liquid
biopsy and site manager kaijin Hannover
Germany dr. Hodge study biology at the
Albert Einstein University in all and
received his PhD in 1997 in plant
physiology in molecular biology at the
Eberhardt Karl's University to begin
until 2001 he was product project
manager for imaging systems and micro
array technologies at biosign
Diagnostics G&B and change thereafter to
a dejenne as marketing manager in 2001
in addition to his marketing
responsibilities he was director of
research and development since 2006 to
build in secure and enhanced antigen
circulating tumor cell business and
after the acquisition by earlier
incorporated in 2010 he was holding the
position of CFO in general manager at
Alire imagine GNB since 2015 dr. Hodge
has served as director of liquid biopsy
and site manager at collagen Hannah
GMB I will now turn it over to dr. house
for his presentation doctor yeah thank
you thank you thank you very much for
this kind introduction and thank you
also for everybody in the auditory for
taking the time to to listen what I have
to tell you about circulating tumor
cells a member of the liquid biopsy
family and its molecular
characterization and as you heard I'm
working since nearly 16 years now in
that field and I would like to share
with you what I observed on the way in
terms of challenges and how we found
solutions to better be able to get
meaningful information out of
circulating tumor cells in patients
blood first of all a little disclaimer
to make sure that you understand that
what we are talking about today is is
really research there is no intention to
make to make you think about using this
information for real patient diagnostics
thank you very much for that ok let's
start with the aDNA test as such so this
is the test I was able to develop with
my team and in order to understand the
challenges and solutions we found on the
way you probably need to understand a
little bit more about the test the
principle as such ok ok so in what is
this test doing actually so how do we
address and access the circulating tumor
cells it is actually starting with
something you might already know it's
immuno magnetic capturing you know in
the first instance that we use to get to
enrich the cells from the blood of a
patient enrichment means by the way here
that it is not pure ctc's you get out we
will come later to that because it's one
of the challenges that we always
whatever method you are looking there
you have a contamination of
certain amount of leukocytes which which
needs to be addressed and needs to be
taken into consideration if we think
about molecular characterization of such
cells
what is the difference here that makes
us different from other in you know
magnetic technologies and this is the co
CP principle the co CP principal means
combination of combinations principle
what what is that one of the secrets
here is that the first combination of
these combinations is a combination of
antibodies directed against surface
antigens on tumor cells and when I say a
mixture I mean that we are not only
using AB chem as many others do but we
use several antibodies up to four to
capture the cells the reason why we use
this mixture is that already in 2004 we
realized and have recalled it at that
time tumor cell viability which is today
known as epithelial to mesenchymal
transition which means in fact that the
tumor cells in once they entered the
circulation may lose certain specific
antigens they they had before and
changed their phenotype into a
mesenchymal like and for instance in
many cases thirty percent of the cases
in breast cancer for example at cam gets
lost and replaced by other more
mesenchymal like antigens and using
these mixture we make sure that we will
not lose the cells if this is happening
this is then followed not by
visualization of the cells but direct
lysis of the cells mRNA isolation
reverse transcription and PCR and again
and this is the second combination we
are not only looking for one tumor
associated RNA species we are looking
for several marker genes if the I
express the Lord in the rule is the one
of these genes is overexpressed these
can be taken as a proof first of all
that the cell or the signal
Ricard comes from a circulating tumor
cell and we get more information even or
out of that but this I will show you
later the other test as it is today is
quite simple benchtop si as a manual si
consisting of several incubation steps
it starts with plot sampling the blood
is incubated then with the immuno
magnetic beet mixture for 30 minutes and
and this is followed then by several
washing steps to get rid of most of the
leukocytes and all the red blood cells
to be the year already a kind of an idea
of the purity we had out here so after
the whole procedure the amount of
contaminating leukocytes ranges in the
range about 1,000 leukocytes by using
special procedure which i will mention
later we can even reduce that to 150
leukocytes and this already gives you
access to the overexpression profile of
the many many genes that are quite
special for the cdc's and not for the
contaminating leukocytes and all that is
then followed by kind of a molecular PCR
analysis it could be an agilent for
example use for that and you make kind
of a capillary gel electrophoresis or
what we do now of course as you can
imagine we do qpcr to get a better
quantification of the fragment
concentrations and the overexpression
profile okay there is the test available
so far and as you can see we developed
tests for breast prostate colorectal
opened ovarian cancer but also since we
knew about this EMT and stem cell issue
this phenotype change of the cells we
especially also developed kit systems to
address especially this kind of cells
and we got very interesting results all
of that and this is the air that has EMT
one and EMT two and stem cell and you
see the target genes which means the RNA
jeans that we are analyzing here on the
right hand in this in this table here
okay let's come to the the first
challenge and I already briefly
mentioned that this is the AirCam
problem 16 years ago in I'm not actually
in 2004 the world thought that mmm is
the best market to to enrich and capture
circulating tumor cells with which is
partly true but as I told you this is
unfortunately not true all the time and
people do is also different in many
cancers and by the you by using this
immuno magnetic antibody beat mixture
you really can kind of overcome at least
at least most you can overcome most of
this challenge here I would not say the
mixture will probably not miss also here
and there a cell that would even not
have one of the three genes or so that
we are using here but I would say in
most of the cases and these our results
show quite clearly at least the increase
in sensitivity is obvious and see here
the first example where we did a
comparison in colorectal cancer
comparing an only at them using immuno
magnetic method with the COC P principle
method of the Edna test and you see
there that the the number of samples
positive with the only outcome was in
their case 20% and the corresponding
samples showed an 80% positivity for
circulating tumor cells using the aDNA
test colorectal cancer this might be due
to the fact that we only in this test
the antibody mixture consists only of
different ad camp
variants different EDM antibodies and
already that increases the sensitivity
but also it might be the second combined
the fact that we are using screen
antigens three genes to to identify
positivity which is at Camp
overexpression EGFR overexpression and
CEA overexpression and also that
combination contributes as you can
imagine to the increasing sensitivity
the same we can see even in prostate
cancer and this was quite surprising to
me because I thought prostate cancer is
one of the cancers that is most likely
overall at camp positive and
interestingly it was not the case so in
this little study we did we did at the
Memorial sloan-kettering in New York we
found when we compared again our
prostate cancer capturing using her anti
her to an anti AB cam in combination it
was very similar in cases where the cell
system using only at Kem identified
cells but we found a significant amount
of positivity in circulating tumor cells
also in the fraction where cell search
didn't find anything so that tells me
also in prostate cancer as well as a
slow growing cancer there is a certain
amount of cells that might undergo EMT
and stemness and this can be identified
by using the entity as breast cancer in
quite a good manner in breast cancer we
also can see that this was this was
analyzed by an trio Pulu at all at the
MD Anderson quite a while ago and
published in 2012 you can also see the
benefit of the the use of a combination
of different Mach 1 variants and at cam
antibodies and the increase against at
cam only is from 36 to 53% giving you an
idea about how many EMT like cells in
breast cancer might be lost if you only
use the app cam and it might all this
increase might also be
you again to the second combination
which is f chem Mach one and her two on
the RNA level since if one of these is
positive and not only at cam alone you
have a positive finding of the CDC's
positive result and super interesting
this is a very recent result published
this year in nature scientific reports
in in lung cancer when we compared the
ANA test EMT to actually the which was
not really dedicated to lung cancer but
using antibodies against at cam her2 and
EGFR in combination and we compare that
again to a pure AB cam based isolation
method you can see that we get a 100%
better sensitivity an increase from 15
to 30% over all the stages of samples
that we had here only if we analyze pi3k
akt 2 and LD LD h 1 and use the antibody
mixture for capturing interestingly by
the way this is not really clear here in
that picture dear therefore I tell you
you see that 80% of the cells we are
captured here were alt H one positive
giving you a very good idea about that
actually most of the CT sees that we are
captured by using the antibody mix was
already probably in in a stem tumor stem
cell-like state or at least in the EMT
state okay now we have
this sensitivity issues due to the fact
that we in the past underestimated the
variability of the ctc's and tendency of
these cells to mimic themselves or mimic
their epithelial origin by undergoing
EMT and the second the second bias if we
now think about molecular
characterization is the effect this most
bestest with the described probably with
purity I do not know so many
technologies actually I do not know any
technology that is really able to purify
ctc's really there is always
contaminating leukocytes still present
and if you think about that we have in a
five milliliter blood sample you have
five times ten to the seventh leukocytes
there and you can reduce it already mm
this is a dramatic increase in purity
nevertheless certain genes that we would
like to analyze on the transcriptome
level will also be present in leukocytes
and the more leukocytes we have the more
bias we make add at least in in in
certain genes and how could we
circumvent that probably this is only to
illustrate a little bit this is a
leukocyte spiking experiment that I can
show you here where you really can see
for a certain number of genes that might
be of interest in in CTC research like a
KT to notch par pi3k as as EMT EMT
markers but also interestingly is likely
her2 and the SRC one that has probably
one day a kind of a therapy related
meaning you can see that the leukocytes
indeed show an expression profile for
these genes and this must be taken into
consideration really if we would like to
exclude such a bias from our CTC results
first of all for the normal Etna test
combinations
you can see that to reduce the leukocyte
count below 1000 leukocytes if you
analyze jeans like AirCam her 2 or mock
one is good enough so 1000 leukocytes
allow you to address these jeans and
allow you to analyze these profiles even
even in the follow-up during a trial or
something looks quite stable you see the
specificity here is coming close to 100%
whereas the recovery ranges for two
cells at 95 percent or 90 percent and
4/5 cells is coming close to 100% so for
their selected genes that we are using
in the traditional kids the leukocyte
problem is already not biasing out our
results but what is about more we do not
only want to know really is the tumor
cell there or not we would like to
analyze more genes like giving pathway
information which pathway molecular
pathway switched on and off what would
be potential therapeutic targets of the
future what is the tumor biology and I
would like to have as much genes as
possible
and in that case 1000 local sites turned
out to be really too much it took quite
a while until we found a solution how we
can reduce the leukocytes even by
another lock to 100 to 150 leukocytes
and this is possible due to a special
washing buffer we developed and that
which we use instead of PBS doing the
first washing steps on the magnetic
beads illustrated here you can see the
cd45 signal that we get with our no wash
and without at no motion you can clearly
see that the fragment concentration
without the aDNA wash is dramatically
higher given here in monochrome per
microliter fragment concentration if you
don't use the aDNA wash and it gets
through
radically reduced if you use the Aetna
wash buffer during the cell enrichment
process and doing so oops that was to
the posterior doing that we were able to
address at least in the first instance
the EMT related genes let me give you a
short overview what I mean when I'm
talking about EMT and to most eminence
the theory behind that is that in a
tumor the priority of the cells you can
get there our kind of differentiated
cells and our kind of actually not
actively dividing cells anymore probably
they are already necrotic the driver of
the tumor and the driver of metastasis
is not this kind of cells the driver of
metallization is a very small population
of cells in the tumor tissue known today
as s tumor stem cells and these tumors
themselves for whatever reason one day
release we get out of the tumor in walk
into their or entered the circulation
actually - as an as an mesenchymal cell
and in the circulation T cells transform
to tumor stem cells with the Kempner
capacity to form metastases how can we
address such cells or how can we can we
say that the first finding we had in
that in that in that view is that
actually we found even in 2006 already
that there is a difference actually if
we analyze tumor tissue and the CT sees
for example viewing - her - if we stain
the tissue for her - and compare it to
the corresponding CTCs
and there her - over expression profile
we find 50 percent of the cells or 50
percent of the samples are
comparable and another 50% are different
so you have roughly 30% of the of the
ctc's in debt study was negative for her
- whereas the histology in the tissue
was positive but more interestingly you
had 21% her2 positive ctc's whereas the
histology of the tissue was negative
that means in principle that there is a
number of cells that develop redevelops
or expresses her - as a growth factor
probably as a kind of resistance
metabolism that was not there before but
is induced by a therapeutic intervention
and also genes like the estrogen
receptor and the progesterone receptor
which can be addressed using the ad noir
suddenly show kind of variations in
tissue versus the circulating tumor
cells but other than her - where we see
a high proportion of the novel developed
expression which was not there in the
tissue the estrogen receptor and the
progress during row receptor get
strongly down regulated once the cells
go into the circulation with which is
again a kind of a marker
what tumor stem cell means because tumor
stem cell is not a highly proliferative
cell that you must stem cell is a cell
that has increased survival mechanism
and has them has a metastatic capacity
but in the blood stream it's getting
silenced and this might be kind of
described here by there by the down
regulation of the estrogen receptor and
the progress Aurora cetera and if we
then look for EMT and tumor stem less
related markers really we see indeed we
have been right and these are results
with edna wash prepared cells because
without that it's not possible to
address these genes like twist
- and ti3 k which unknown EMT markers in
breast cancer or the a ADH one which is
a stem cell marker in breast cancer and
many others have obviously here what
really happens is that if CT sees our
into circulation I would I would say
based on these results here nearly all
of them at least eighty percent of them
taking everything together are either
EMT like or tumor stem analysis stem
cell like that means in other words that
meta position is that a number of the
Optus of this low frequency cells that
have already the stemness
this stemless capability in the tissue
is really the phenotype of cells that
leaves the tumor enters the circulation
and is the seed of metallization at
least based on these results here what
else can we do oops if we see such
results and this is a very simple thing
once you have such results and you know
now you have two methodology and could
overcome the AirCam problem and the
leucocyte fires then you have now
suddenly access to probably a great
number of genes in parallel only a few
genes is not enough and this was the
reason actually why we decided to go for
a panel develop what we wanted to know
more and the first panel that we
developed here which is by the way not
commercially available this was really
the first try but already successful was
a panel consisting of epithelial like
genes genes that are in EMT metabolism
important and genes of the two most M&S
family like cd44 or ADH one and we
clearly could see that using the Edit
test enrichment process and the cDNA be
developed in with these kids was enough
material to really address up to what is
it here
say 20 genes or so because this is a
random number that we usually use if we
do now aDNA panels or if you develop now
aDNA panels and you can see in this
little preliminary trial in 18 patients
we got a real nice differential
expression of of these different genes
and could address that very nicely and
also in the individual situation you can
see the in the differential expression
of the genes gives you clear information
or at least you could interpret clearly
information out of there and this is
shown here in kind of logistics in four
samples so we have patient example G
where we can see in this panel only AB
chem is overexpressed in the cDNA we got
from perfil death patient and in patient
P we have only her to the at cam is not
there but also not other genes of the
EMT pathways or d2 most feminist pathway
whereas patient M is in my eyes exclude
tumor stem cell-like phenotype that we
captured here cd44 is their twist is
their mTOR pi3k all indications that
both EMT metabolism but also tumor tumor
stem cell-like metabolism is switched on
and another interesting profile is
patient E because in the first instance
you would say yeah cd44 is on therefore
this is a tumor stem cell-like cell but
we also see at camp suddenly we see p10
which is actually an inhibitor an
intrinsic inhibitor of the EMT pathway
of the pi3k pathway and we see suddenly
K R us that could give us an idea about
if it's not the pi3k pathway in breast
cancer that is making the metabolism of
the cell dangerous is K R us probably
resistance mechanism can can we see them
applying these this kind of panels we
hope yes at least it's an invitation to
do more research in that direction
to to see what what is really happening
in this cell during a therapy for
example or as a consequence of a therapy
a resistance development or as a
consequence of therapy response even how
do we see how do these cells react on
that is there a metabolic change and a
change in to what direction and would
this give us in future necessary
information to be able to better react
on that to earlier treat patients with
the right target targets and the right
drugs developed for the certain targets
our our wish was when we did this
research we wanted to be able at least
to kind of build a scale where we could
sort patients in that might have ctc's
that are not really dangerous
there are probably not seeds of
metallization which is the more
epithelial likes and we wanted to find
out another group of patients that is
develop a more aggressive cell type and
and we're on the scale could we could we
build in depth the patient patients here
and and in our case it's very clear
patient GE was the only attempt was an
example for team or epithelial like
patient P you remember that was the one
where we had the only her to expression
I would see not already EMT like but on
the way there probably patient II is the
more EMT like and patient am the more
stem cell-like
and the big question that comes here now
the position on that scale is that
indicate is about prognostic risk of the
patient or not and this is a question of
studies that have to be done really to
confirm it other panels
developed afterwards based on these
results because we also had jeans on the
first panel that never appeared in
breast cancer was the first panel that
we developed here for breast cancer that
will be probably commercially available
soon and this is consisting of at cami
RCC one her to a KT EGFR her three pi3k
a idh1 and Aurora kinase and when we did
first studies with that panel we first
wanted to know is there a change in the
profile of these genes if we look at it
before and after therapy and we found
yeah there were slight changes in terms
of EGFR and her - so her - is
upregulated after therapy EGFR in these
cases was down regulated asked Tara P in
frequency a idh1 as expected so if there
were cells after therapy is still there
a high proportion of them was LD as one
positive and the interesting thing here
is Aurora kinase was exclusively over
expressed only themselves we found after
therapy but never before the more
important question for us was was there
a correlation with terribly responds or
not and here the picture was a little
different we group the the genes we had
there in epithelial related genes in
receptor expression genes in resistance
markers in EMT lights and in stem cell
likes and in deed also the epithelial
like plays a role as it looks in the
group of the non-responders as you can
see here whereas the receptor expression
did not differ but two resistance
markers like ER c c1 and and aurora
kinase were correlated with the
non-response group whereas d responders
were lower in frequency and surprise
surprise also the stem cell likes again
followed this route nearly exclusively
observed in the non-responder groups
whereas nearly not not
expressed in the responder groups dead
was not only nice results but also
statistically in many cases significant
you can see here that after therapy
epithelial likes were significantly
present in after therapy in these kind
of cases the stem cell likes also after
therapy but we found also combinations
like EGFR and her royal highness that
was already kind of indicated before
therapy and this is a very interesting
finding because the question is
appearing here would we really like to
only have a monitoring or would we
really like to only have a kind of a
prognostic information or would CTC
probably also be able to give us a kind
of predictive information before a
therapy started which might be the right
regimen to give or not and this is the
first indications here if you look at
combinations like EGFR or upcoming
combination with our roller kinase or
all the three all they were significant
correlated before therapy which gives us
at least the idea that it might be
possible that the molecular
characterization of ctc's might give us
instead of prognostic information also
predictive information in the future one
could do it even one step further you
have seen that we developed a panel with
20 genes others develop panels with even
more genes and this is an example coming
from Katerina Colo Slava in at the
Bauhaus University cultural University
in Prague they had a panel there for
there is a typo I see it was actually 48
genes they analyzed for and they made
the following study first of all they
generated cDNA by using the Aetna tests
the EMT won and stem cell and generate
the cDNA and analyzed use
the agilent for positivity or not only
only dead in parallel they also analyzed
the cDNA for the affording a gene
expression panel also they took FFPE
tissue and analyzed for the same panel
and compared it to the CTC findings and
this is what they found and this is a
very interesting result if you ask me so
that's probably give us an an idea at
least at least a week vision what is
really happening during a metastasis on
process and and how can we how can we
make research reset you can see here in
light blue the partial clustering
results of the tissue and in darker in
black you can see the cities at the
positive CTC findings that we had in
metastatic disease and in green you see
the positive CTC findings in primary
disease and in what is that purple you
see the negative ad net has negative
samples first of all that tells us and
that's nice the negative samples are
grouping away from all the other groups
that gives you an idea about the
specificity of the tests if we don't
find the CTC is they they do not group
to the CTC group on also not to the
tissue and also the metastatic ctc's
have only a minimal overlap with the
tissue that was surprising actually for
me but kind of following the route that
really in during the metallization
process significant changes apply here
and probably this is driven by the
phenotype of the CT sees that go in the
circulation and form the metastasis and
the CT sees in the primary situation
they overlap both groups the tissue and
the metastatic
dc's and here comes now my idea I'm not
sure if it's true but it's worth
thinking about it do we see here if we
look in the primary DCTC group and if we
take the sub group of primary ctc's that
fall into the FFPE tissues under group
is that a CTC type that is still
expressing kind of a non dangerous
tissue light phenotype but already you
find CTC is in the primary group that
have a profile that overlaps with the
metastatic disease is that the subgroup
in the primary that gives you already
the information that this CT C's are on
the way or already kind of acquired
metastatic metabolism ready to for
metastasis interesting findings here we
keep on researching on that let's see in
the year from now we will have have more
information probably let me summarize
the molecular detection of circulating
tumor cells have proven to be a highly
sensitive method and very specific by
using the combination of combinations
principle making sure that we get the
maximum sensitivity out without losing
the specificity as I was able to show
you in the case of editors breast the co
CP principle has turned out to really
improve the sensitivity substantially
making again or again again as a proof
that is really true that certain genes
get lost once the cells get into the
circulation especially if some some
phenomenon like EMT or to misdemeanors
Ness appears the molecular
characterization of CTC has been proven
to be able to identify EMT and tumor
stem cell related phenotypes by means of
molecular biology and gives an
indication about molecular pathways that
might be involved in metastasis from a
metastasis formation but more
importantly
that might be involved in resistance
formation because that could in future
give us ideas about how to overcome
resistance really if we see what is the
reason for the resistance we have at
least an idea about what could we do to
get to get to to overcome the resistance
and to help the patient and the most
important final information I could give
you today on this call the other test is
an open platform that enables you the
researchers to have your own ideas what
would you like to analyze what kind of
tumor type would you like to analyze in
what direction would it be more kind of
targeted and analysis in terms of drug
resistance or something would it be into
the direction of better characterization
of the overall CTC metabolism everything
is open you have the cDNA you can
develop your own tests and you can find
your own results and this is the most
important message which I would like to
place here as a final and with that I
thank you for your attendance I thank
you for your patience patience following
me all the time and I'm ready now for
questions if there are some Thank You
dr. hatch for that informative
presentation and before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is can the aDNA test
be used be used as a mouse lymphoma
model or would you need to optimize
antibody as the NSC marker as they might
be different yeah that's
that's the case for sure so if we talk
about lymphoma this has nothing to do
with epithelial cancers which I was
demonstrating new today nevertheless I
mean the principle stays in fact the
same so what one needs to find the
relevant markers that that are useful
for capturing and of course relevant
molecular markers we would like to see
then afterwards in their expression
profile in principle it's possible in
reality we didn't focus on on lymphoma
and such kind of cancers because we were
more focusing on under the the
epithelial ones and the solid ones
excellent thank you our second question
asks can you discriminate between
Matassa
and non metallic patients okay if I
understood you right it means metastatic
or non metastatic patients yes yes yes
simple answer yes so there is a nice
piece of work we did recently in the
group of the University of Essen where
we could show that the profiles that we
find in the non metastatic disease if
there are CT sees is in has indeed big
differences against the the metastatic
profile and even more what we found
there there seems also to be in the
metastatic situation a kind of
preference genes that are related to the
site of metastasis on that means also
you can use the metastatic profile to
identify statistically I have to say
it's not an identification for sure but
there is a statistical correlation to
the site of meta stars Asian even thank
you we have an additional question can
the aDNA test system detect one CTC in
one mil blood yes it's a simple question
in the simple answer perfect how
sensitive is the ad Natak yes
sensitivity is is and
how should we describe sensitivity we
can describe it in two ways one way is
that we would have a technical
sensitivity for which the name is
recovery if I do
spiking experiments using cultivated
cultured cells I get recovery rate of 90
percent if I spiked two cells in 5 ml of
blood so there is a technical
sensitivity you will now go to the
clinical sensitivity so that means what
is the frequency the rate of the cells
we get if we for example look into a
cohort of metastatic patients or primary
patients the clinical sensitivity in the
primary situation over all the cancers I
demonstrate here might it be colon
ovarian breast or prostate or such is
between 20 and 30 percent in the primary
situation means 30% of the patients
before surgery or something are positive
for ctc's usually in the metastatic
situation this can go up to 70 percent
clinical sensitivity again dependent on
the situations or when I say 70 75
percent that means non not treated not
treatment nice but was also in the in
between the treatments also at least
four weeks no treatment then it can go
up to 75 percent positivity for ctc's in
metastatic samples okay thank you for
that our next question how early or
which stage in cancer development is it
possible to detect ctc's in patients
blood
that's a good question thank you for
that
I had it only once in the last four
years but it's a really good question so
if your tumor
is small or large if there is already
nodal involvement or not
CTC is the frequency of CTC is not
correlated to that you'll find or the
same frequency in let's say T 1 and 0 M
0 breast cancer patients as well as in T
3 n 2 and so that means circulating
tumor cells are in an independent marker
over the normal staging parameters okay
thank you
next question in addition to CTC channel
in disease how can you perform tumor
specific mutation measurements in ctc's
yeah so of course we did research on
that and we were able actually to do it
in the case of colorectal cancer we were
able to really find ctcs with K Rus
mutations in that case it was caught on
12 that have had been had been actually
very preliminary experiments I have to
admit so that was not our focus in the
past but we do more and more work on
that because we have seen at least a
proof of principle for colorectal cancer
was there and at least also we got an
interesting finding here in that case
because we could see that decay rust
mutations we found in the CDC's we are
not necessarily also found in the tissue
and vice-versa
so we found in this in this little study
published by by power lockets a [ __ ] or
Raimondi Raimondi at all from the pali
clinical in rome they found tissue that
was positive for k-rod codon 12
mutations but the CTS were not but also
the other way around we found tissue
initially negative for the mutation but
suddenly K Rus mutations were there in
the circulating tumor cells which might
be the case because of the let's say
these tumor stem cells are so rare in
tissue
you might overlook them but once you
capture them in the circulation
specifically by using the a test for
example there there might be a higher
chance to find the mutated ones really
in the circulation thank you excellent
um if there are no more questions I
would like once again to thank you dr.
house for his presentation dr. house do
you have any final closing comments yes
I probably have two to two comments so
first of all again thank you for giving
me the chance to to have this webinar
today
second the auditory thanks again for
your patience and for your contribution
in terms of questions and the third hey
let's do research together it's a good
field and we are getting further and
further and for the sake of the patient
we should find good solutions in the
future thank you so much I would also
like to thank our sponsor kaya Jen for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available on-demand viewing through
February 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots fleuti alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcements that announcements rather
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events thank you so much
and see you next time
from laborat good bye bye